Imamo kurs kursničke primude,
imamo pravna pravila,
kursona pravila
koja ima uređenu funkcionisanu državu
i pomenuli smo dva osnovna
principa funkcionisanog države
koja su podlano čelo subordinacija
i koordinacija.
Subordinacija i odnos nadređenosti
i podređenosti koju imamo državno
dajem na različitom stepenu vlasti.
Koordinacija ima isti stepen vlasti
i saraje.
To je ono što smo prošlog puta radili
i gde smo se zaustavili.
Sada idemo dalje. Kada je reč o ljudima?
Krenut ćemo sa ljudima da vidimo
koji to ljudi rade, šta rade,
kako rade i kakav je njihov odnos
prema državi kao organizaciju.
Dakle, državu kao organizaciju
ne čine svi građani,
ne čini svo stanovništvo,
taj državni aparat čine samo neki ljudi.
Ti ljudi koji čine taj državni aparat,
oni se nazivaju državnim službenim ljude.
Dakle, to su ljudi
koji rade u imenu za račun država.
Tim državnim službenim
licima se daju određene
poslove.
Ima potređena državna službena ulica,
da se mu da rade neki posao
i taj posao predstavlja njegovu
radu. Ja se obudim
da vam što jednostavnije objasnim,
ne da se držim tih definicija iz učbenika,
nego najprostije je moguće
da vam objasnim.
Dakle uzmeš neki posao, daš ga jednom
državnom tvrdnom ulicu i kažeš evo ti,
napravo radi to, to je tvoja nadležnost.
Postoje dve vrste nadražnosti,
u principu
i ova treća nekakva funkcionalna,
to je uopšte nije zakonska kategorija,
ali se često spominje,
pa ćemo nju objasniti,
i prisutna je naravno u radu državnih
ordana, ali nije zakonska kategorija.
Da krenemo od stvarne, dakle,
ako uzmete recimo jednog sudija
koji je državno službeno lice
i jednog narodnog poslanika
koji je državno službeno lice,
da li oni radi isti?